en esta cabaña de los suburbios de lyon
varias veces a la semana mar y visita a
stella
[Música]
con su abuela
en esta casita vive estela con sus dos
hijos solo tiene unos veinte metros
cuadrados pero poco importa
[Música]
estamos muy cómodos aquí estamos
calientitos nos sentimos como en casa
estamos en nuestra casita si no
compartimos la cocina no compartimos el
baño es mejor que lo que solíamos tener
cuando nos quedábamos en viviendas
compartidas mucho mejor
este es nuestro hogar solo somos los
niños y yo desde su llegada a francia en
2018 estela se ha alojado donde ha
encontrado sitio a menudo con amigos
pasando de un alojamiento a otro pero a
principios de noviembre una asociación
le ofreció instalarse en una cabaña
especialmente diseñada para acoger a
mujeres sin hogar con sus hijos hasta
que encuentre una solución más duradera
el cierto que las madres son muy felices
porque les permite encontrar un entorno
de vida una vida familiar con su propia
intimidad su propio espacio lo cual es
valioso para la gente que ha estado en
la calle que tuvo que soportar la falta
de privacidad ese tipo de cosas
[Música]
hay 6 cabañas más como ésta forman parte
de los proyectos financiados por la
empresa de posibilidades un colectivo
que sirve de puente entre las empresas y
sus empleados que quieren ayudar y las
asociaciones que apoyan a las personas
sin hogar el proyecto fue lanzado en
2019 por el famoso industrial leonés a
la misión
[Música]
el fixture pop no existe eso de dejar a
la gente en la calle no existía cuando
yo era niño
recuerdo mi infancia como cualquier
persona que envejece y puede recordar su
infancia en el pueblo de mis abuelos no
había gente en la calle así que intentó
recrear esa solidaridad mucho tiempo
después yo diría una forma evidente de
compartir
en concreto las empresas pueden ayudar
de varias maneras pueden por ejemplo dar
dinero poner a disposición sus
conocimientos o locales pero también
pueden solicitar a sus empleados
[Música]
el empleado puede optar por participar
en misiones de voluntariado pero si no
tiene tiempo también puede dar uno o más
días libres con sueldos así que hay
flexibilidad el objetivo es crear esta
nueva forma de solidaridad estableciendo
un vínculo entre los empleados de la
empresa y las personas sin hogar
de personas
un enfoque flexible y sobre todo muy
convincente porque el empleado no tiene
la sensación de sacar dinero de su
bolsillo
simplemente renuncia a uno o varios días
libres que luego se monetizan y se donan
a asociaciones que ayudan a los sintecho
así lo confirma merck que ha implantado
un sistema en algunas de sus sucursales
ya en 2019
[Música]
para nuestra gran sorpresa en el primer
año nos vienen 63 días de permiso así
que funcionó muy muy bien
hay dos factores claves de éxito que son
indispensables el primero es la
transparencia el segundo la sencillez en
la comunicación y en la donación de los
días con nosotros se hace con un clic
donde sea
[Música]
y en contra de lo que podría pensarse a
pesar de la pandemia de coronavirus en
2020 los empleados fueron aún más
generosos no sólo los de merck sino en
general los de las 60 empresas que se
han sumado a la empresa de posibilidades
en menos de dos años de existencia el
colectivo ha recaudado más de un millón
de euros una cantidad que ha dado cobijo
a más de 550 personas sin hogar
[Música]